[Music]
hello youtube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my fifty
second episode of dirty chance tricks
in this episode I am going to show you
one of the most attacking line and in
fact a mini recruit are against Banco
gambit the good point
I like about this opening is not only it
contains a lot of tricks but your
opponent has to know the theory very
well
otherwise game can be decide very very
quickly the Banco gambit arises after
the falling water d4 Knight to f6 c4 c5
now I'd grab the space in the Queen side
with d5 and accordingly black hit back
the center with B Phi and gambit upon
well why should certainly capture this
pawn and when black offers the second
pawn for a rapid fast development we
should not capture it and instead of
that develop our piece with Knight to c3
and I think already Black has to be
careful a good banker player will
understand that only a captures B fire
is a right move and in fact in the
database most of the games goes into
that direction however even have seen
strong players made other sideline moves
such as g6 or d6 which I'm afraid a
great deal of inaccuracy the simple
reason is against all the sidelines
let's say g6 white is going to continue
with fo grabbing superb space in the
center of the ball and giving extra
option to capture this pawn with a shop
here white is already threatening e5 so
black has to prevent this with d6 and
after that white can just develop their
pcs on the national square such as
Knight to f3 and with the
wonderful center I don't think so white
has any sort of problem against Banco
gambit I have attached a model game in
the PGN which will give you a very good
idea how effectively white pieces can
flow over the board and kill the black
so it is very obvious that no-good Banco
player will allow this and they are
definitely going to capture on b5 which
is in fact the only logical reply so as
you can see black get his pawn back and
if white become greedy and captured on B
fire then resulting position I don't
like it so instead of that I am
proposing this very cunning and tricky
mu e fo so if now allowed then white
will definitely capture with Bishop so
accordingly black has to push forward
with b4 attacking the knight and the
same time if the knight moves then the
e4 pawn drops so isn't that white has
made a blunder in the opening well of
course not this is all plan and
surprisingly enough white knight comes
forward with Knight to B Phi which at
first sight looks completely ridiculous
because that Knight doesn't have any
backward route however as we are going
to see it has some amazing attacking
potentials we reach to the starting
position of the nescafé frappé edition
and the first cunning trick I want to
highlight here that if the opponent is
not familiar with this territory then he
is likely to turn out this mistake
namely Knight captures efore looks
obvious right winning a pawn but this is
the last time your opponent is going to
capture this pawn as after the move
quint we do we are attacking the knight
and unfortunately that Knight cannot
move
why what happens if Knight to f6 yep you
guessed it it is this amazing smooth is
made with somehow if you get it then you
definitely want to post it on your FB
page well some of you says okay but I
don't need to move the knight I can
support it right with Fi well yes you
can
but after f3 still that Knight cannot
move the simple reason is again we have
Knight to d6 Jack and that night also
covered Epsom square and that means good
night black ink so now it's clear that
black cannot even touch that pawn and
more deadly is what is coming forward
with ePHI something which black has to
prevent so d6 is the obvious response at
this position okay
no issues what is going to continue with
Bishop to c4 once again offering the e4
pawn which black dare not to take it if
you carefully look at this position you
may think this time I can definitely
take this pawn as after the move Queen
to e to the d6 square is protected and
now black and simply it retrieve the
knight back to f6 and everything is
intact well yep the time being it looks
like but after why it's next to apply
Bishop to F for that d6 pawn is a simply
corner there is no concrete way black
and defend this and in fact after Knight
to d6 black position is going to crumble
so the only logical reply here is rook
to e6 trying to get to piece for a rook
but tactically this is not working the
simple reason is after Knight captures
d6 rook captures d6
white has this deciding checkol Bishop
to be Phi which conforms the winning
advantage if Knight o Bashar comes in
between then the rook on d6 will hang
and if black still insists to play rook
d7 hoping that he will get to peace for
a rook but unfortunately what black
missed out is his knight on b8 hanging
and simply what he's going to take this
nine and on the next turn he's going to
get the rook and in fact the game so you
can see how tricky these positions are
and still black cannot touch that
efore pawn so accordingly if you check
this position in online database you
will find out that here there are two
popular choices by black namely g6 and
Knight B to d7 now before I was making
this video I have done some heavy
research and my conclusion about those
two additions are in almost all the
lines white get tremendous attacking
positions for example let's start with
g6 which is one of the most popular
choice here so idea is very simple
typical Bank of style black wants to
play Bishop g7 and castle on the King
side however against nescafé frappé
variation this is not a good choice here
comes one of the most aggressive blonde
by white starting with ePHI attacking to
spot so black responses force black has
to capture on e5 and after that can you
guessed it yup absolutely right
next Bond goes forward d6 sacrificing
the second pawn and this bone black has
to take otherwise Knight c7 land with
devastation so he captures d6
and for a time being black has two extra
pawn but the matter of fact is he get a
completely losing position after White's
next dazzling reply Bishop to g5 so idea
is very simple what white wants to do is
he wants to capture this nine and when
black recaptured with the Queen white
once reliever this check which NAB's the
rook in the corner so to defuse this
idea as I have highlighted over here
black has various responses but neither
of them are walking let's see each bite
on the first move I want to consider is
Knight to a6 which on the surface looks
so good as it covers the c7 spot but
just one move and black and resign did
you spot it good if you find this move
as your tactical eye is very sharp the
screen is attacking to sports and black
cannot defend both of them so from this
position black is going to lose a piece
and in fact the game well the second
bear move is Bishop to e7 so that Bishop
is required to protect on d6 and by
moving to the e7 black has given up the
control on d6 so white response is very
obvious Bishop captures f6 Bishop
captures f6 and now Knight captures d6
which not only misplaced the black King
but after Knight captures f7 y --t
instantly get his to pawn back with a
completely winning position a simple
line can draw like this Queen kept a
Steven check Luke kept a Steven and now
as the rook in the corner hangs so rook
to g8 looks the only logical reply
afterwards we have this little move
Knight to d6
which by force winning the exchange and
in fact the game the third who I want to
consider is Knight B to d7 which is
again not a good move if you know the
repetition very well well as happen in
many case White has one little move
which completely destroyed black
position and here it comes with Quinn to
p3 so idea is very simple white one to
capture on f7 and black cannot play
Queen to e7 as Knight to c7 hangs the
rook in the corner so simply black
cannot even defend on f7 and to
illustrate how dangerous this position
is for the black we are going to now
follow a game between two international
master wear black decided to continue
with Knight to b6 attacking the bishop
bishop to f7 his obvious response and
after king to e7 white
continue with his energetic style looked
at even picking up the loose d6 pot
well black tried to wriggle out with c4
but this doesn't turn out well as after
Bishop captures e4 Knight captures e4
Queen captures sifu yes black and
untangle his species somewhat with
Bishop to b6 attacking the Queen
but after Queen to h4 black position is
not a pretty sight time being he defend
all the threat with King to f7 but
rightly so after Knight to f3 once white
will Castle black is literally asking
for the trouble he tried at 6 to get rid
of the pin but as the rook on h8 is
unprotected white simply castle on the
Kings side and now finally King to g7
create the threat of H cups of g5 and
maybe black thought over here that I am
right back
in the game but to his horror white
believer this nasty blue night to see
seven Pam and suddenly black get a
completely losing position
the problem here is he cannot capture on
GFI the simple reason is after night
captures a six check King to g8 and now
Queen captures rook and in the next turn
what is going to take the queen with a
decisive material advantage so that's
not a good choice for the black and in
the game black tried to save the rook
with queen capture c7 but after the
obvious continuation Bishop captures f6
Jack King to g8 and Bishop captures h8
faheen of black cannot even touch that
Bishop as his own Bishop will hang after
the Queen check you can check out rest
of the game in the PG n which only lasts
for 25 moves the fourth move I want to
consider is Bishop to b7 which is
somewhat good reply against this
variation and against this I am going to
propose a very tactical line starting
with Bishop to defy so we are taking
benefit of pinned f6 Knight and black
response is almost forced he has to
capture on d5 afterwards we throw this
Intermezzo Bishop captures up 6
attacking the Queen and after Queen
takes and Queen takes Bishop the rook on
the corner hangs and no matter wherever
this rook moves let's say rook to e4
afterwards we can continue with Knight
to c7 check so already black King has
been misplaced and on top of everything
White has severe threats going on with
Queen to p7 attacking tonight Knight to
d7 and now White has this winning move
Knight to d5
so you can see the sequence is pretty
much forced and after this move black
queen has to stay in protection of D H
square otherwise Queen to c7 and then
Queen to c8 leads to the checkmate
Queen to h4 only logical reply but after
this white has just one move which kills
the black that is very calm but very
effective like to eat too so not only
stopping Queen check but White has a
simple idea to play g3 as fire kicking
this queen out of this diagonal and then
deliver the checkmate on CH which
amazingly enough not easy to stop so for
example let's say if Bishop to g7 then
we have g3 twin to g5 h 4 and once the
Queen move we have Queen check King yet
and Quincy 8 checkmate in one of the
recent game black has tried the move
Bishop to e7 which has a simple idea to
safeguard the da square with the bishop
but unfortunately this is not working as
well the simple reason is White has this
deciding move
threatening checkmate as well as on the
roof
so black responses force black has to
capture on b6 afterwards we are going to
recapture and the problem arise that
wherever this King goes White Queen will
deliver check and then at the end NAB
the roof on the a Foursquare King do 7
Queen be fine game over time for the
black camp last but not least what
happens if you open and continue with
rook to be fi well I must say this move
will be only played by opponent which
knows this variation very well as this
is one of the most critical response
again
nescafé frappé edition here black has
tried various responses but I am going
to propose this straightforward move
Knight to f3 still black cannot complete
his kingside development as if the
bishop moves then we can capture this
Knight and then capture on d6 so
accordingly black has to get rid of this
pesky g5 bishop and that six is the only
logical reply by black okay we are not
going to waste any time in this
variation we will capture on AB 6 and
after Queen takes we will first deliver
this check which will misplace the black
King and then Knight comes back to the
superior square defy queen has the only
logical response Queen to a5 so this
sequence is almost forced and after this
only thing you have to remember is play
the star mu a 3 which has a simple
intention to open up the a file and
generate a quick attack against this
week black ink
well if you oppor and capture on a3 then
I have attached a sample line in the PGN
which will give you a great idea how to
create initiative but as per the
database there are only two games reach
to this position and in both the games
black continue with Queen to e4 which I
personally think you are going to see in
your game well against this my
recommendation is you should continue
893 defending c4 Bishop and more or less
follow up with the same plan we want to
castle and then open up the file one of
the high level game here continue with
Bishop to b6 and in the game white
continue with a captures b4 which at the
end turn out well but instead of that my
recommendation here is you should play
Knight to d2 I improvement of that game
and I think after this move black is
completely lost yes you heard it right
as once the Queen move anywhere let's
say Queen to see six the problem in this
position is after Knight to b3 that pure
rook on a file has been trapped down
group to a4 what else and after this
White has this dazzling moon might get
to see Phi attacking twice on the roof
and in fact endian suggests that black
should capture this night and give up
this rook which indeed doesn't turn out
well as after Bishop capture Sifu Quinto
eight attacking the knight and black
cannot defend with the Queen as the c-4
Bishop will drop so King to see it looks
the only logical reply but after rook to
seven by force white will win the piece
and in fact the game some of you ask but
what about the simple route to e Phi and
we are more than happy to take a draw
that's not the case here because the
forcing sequence continues with Knight
capture c6 Knight captures e6 pawn
captures before attacking the rook and
after rook takes room Queen takes rook
Knight to c7 and now Castle on the Kings
side it's a case where the material
balance has been restored but look at
the black development there is hardly
any piece develop on the Kings side and
on top of everything black king is stuck
in the center which in many of this line
has a deciding factor
last but not least what happens if you
open and continue with Knight B to d7
well I must say after this move why it
doesn't have much of the tricks but why
it doesn't even have to sacrifice any
material and get a good position out of
pate so I'm giving you a sample line
which will give you a very good idea how
to play against Knight bd7 why it should
start with Knight to f3 and after Knight
to b6 attacking the bishop we should
preserve our Bishop with Bishop to d3
there is a small trick here guys if you
open and continue with c4 which is a
blunder move and so I can simply capture
this pawn and after Knight capture c4
and the move Queen to c2
once again we trap the knight as if the
knight moves then knight on c7 create
havoc in the black camp so accordingly
many games continue from here onwards
with g6 trying to complete the King side
piece development but white is more than
happy as after the move b3 Bishop to g7
Bishop to b3 Castle castle Bishop to e6
and now the star moon fo not only
confirms the space advantage by white
but White has many active plants from
this position which you can try out and
the most important factor I like about
this variation is there is hardly any
Benko pressure on the Queen side which
actually black is playing for I have
attached one of the model game in the PG
n which will give you a very good idea
how to play from this position that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and on this mini
lecture on the nescafé frappé edition
which is one of my favorite attacking
system against Benko gambit just like me
you can do
research about this line as it has not
been explored properly and if you do
your homework well then I'm definitely
sure that in the to now in practice you
can score lots of point in this line
thank you for watching this video guys
feel free to write subscribe and comment
on this video and I'll meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care